this is by far the the weirdest thing
I've been asked to do hello I'm Alex
Honnold I'm a rock climber and I will be
painting a you cemani valley scene while
I answer questions or perhaps just a big
smiley face I mean typically I tell any
beginner just to go to the gym have a
good time and you know try it just enjoy
climbing and do the thing work on the
footwork you practice technique yeah I
mean I guess the main thing about going
climbing is that there's no particular
way to do you just go and try it out
have a good time now on my successful
free solo vocab I felt good and
confident comfortable the whole way
though I mean I had a previous failed
attempt where I obviously fell
uncomfortable but by the time I actually
did it it felt great in that particular
situation I actually climbed another 500
feet up to a big Ledge system and then
there there's a thousand feet of rope
from the ground up to those ledges
climbers always used as a way to commute
up and down the wall in that particular
case I kind of cheated my way up a
couple hundred more feet and then
climbed a bit more and then got to the
ropes and then repelled down but
depending where you are on the wall is
always kind of a different strategy and
how you would potentially descend I need
I need a tree trunk exciting climate
climbing is very serious and nobody
jokes you know climbing is life and
death
like nobody's nobody's having a good
time when they climb it's all much too
serious I need some green hopefully
people find it motivating in whatever
way it's good for them I mean with
audiences everybody sort of chooses
their own little thing from it I met a
woman he'd just signed up for a marathon
after watching it was like it was pretty
cool you know I don't think I want
people to take anything from the movie I
just hope that they get something from
it I need more forest
the normal life I mean I took we wake up
in the van in some climbing area eat
some breakfast go out and climb for the
day and then come back eat some dinner
and go to bed and then repeat it's all
pretty it's a pretty lovely lifestyle
I'm making a rather impressionistic
version of the valley
certainly uneasy free soloing I'm
thinking of all kinds of things
you know I can think about the weather
appreciate the position and enjoy the
actual moves themselves I think about
partners I've been up there with but
then for a harder climbing I have to
fully focus on what I'm actually doing
totally painting put crux II painting
you have to really pay attention this is
the Sentinel I shake on that for 60
minutes once upon a time it's one of my
favorite features in e70 I don't really
think no I mean honestly I don't really
have any hidden talents I don't think
I've put a lot of energy into rock
climbing and not that much energy into
really any other particular skills oh
well I mean painting is gonna become a
new hobby I think I was gonna turn this
all sort of blue it's gonna be nice I
wasn't a professional climber
I'd probably maybe be an engineer or
some kind maybe I was studying that in
school for a little bit I have I have
never seriously injured a finger walk
climbing and everything or I mean I've
only pulled tendons which is the most
common kind of economy injury so in the
film I break my back though I think in
retrospect I didn't actually break my
back I think actually sprained Luqman my
hip and at the time there's an x-ray
like I have some compression fractures
in my back but I think he might be from
an injury when I was when I was much
younger actually I got really really
poor medical care after after that
exhales like this really pretty scrappy
24-hour emergency thing and like the
doctor never even looked at my body like
they just rolled me and took an extra it
rolled me up and they never even
physically looked at the injury or
anything it was kind of a weird
experience and then the ankle injury
basically has just healed over time the
way the way you would expect
I've been vegetarian for maybe five or
six years because the environmental
impact because I feel like it was one of
the few things that I could do
personally to reduce my impact on the
world and then once I wanted vegetarian
I started caring slightly more about the
other thing so to sum once I stopped
being me it's a lot easier to care about
not killing other creatures I mean in
general trying to do no harm is a seems
like a sound principle I think that diet
is probably the easiest thing that most
individuals can do to lower their impact
on the world just because it really can
have almost no impact on your life you
leave the exact same lifestyle you still
take the same pleasure out of life it's
like basically everything remains the
same but you just have a tiny fraction
of the impact on the earth around you
actually I mean the biggest thing that
most people can do with obviously was
vote for people to actually care about
the environment but even more so
actually is changing your bank pretty
much every big bank though is pumpkin
tons of money into politics on both
sides of the aisle supporting all kinds
of things that you personally would
never support no matter where you stand
politically so I mean putting your money
somewhere local and not-for-profit is
probably the maybe the biggest impact
you know I know people don't think about
it but it's like all your money is
living somewhere in someone who's using
it so I started the Chanukah Nation
maybe five six years ago in an effort to
do something positive in the world I
basically felt like you know I had more
than I needed I was living out of my van
I had very little overhead and I was
suddenly making more than I needed and I
felt like I should do something useful
instead I've been donating money to
environmental nonprofits and then we
sort of gravitated towards solar
projects just because my person who's
interested in environmental projects
that also improves standard of living
like things that help the environment
but also help people in need both
domestically and and abroad and
obviously that's been one of the the
highlights of the film pure for me is
that the foundation is sort of tripled
in size and scope I think just in the
last six months I've certainly run into
tons of creatures that were surprised I
mean I've pulled holds off the wall and
found scorpions underneath I remember
really stinky because I was horrified
both times like whoa you know because
you're hanging on and there's something
like scorpion right in front of you so I
be concerned I'm not really call myself
a minimalist I think that I just use
what I need and I don't need that much
because the things that I enjoy doing
don't require that much on them I think
I just think about whether or not I need
something before before I acquire I
don't know that makes me minimalist but
I think that just makes me thoughtful
yeah I can definitely tell you that I
will not be competing in the 2020
Olympics and I've spent the last ten
years of my life focusing on climbing
3,000 foot walls and wild places like
Yosemite and people that are gonna win
the Olympics I've been training inside a
gym you know their entire lives it's
like different sports basically I want
like some kind of nice ground and maybe
I'll try bryggen oh yeah actually I mean
I learned how to skydive thinking that I
was gonna get into BASE jumping because
all my friends had started based
generally in Yosemite and it seemed like
such an efficient way to fly down off
the tops of walls and then basically I
learned how to skydive I realized how
dangerous BASE jumping was and then
decided it wasn't for me there's a big
heart shaped depression on the left side
of El Cap so I added the heart if
somebody tells me that free soloing is
crazy I just I mean I know I don't
really say I mean I don't care people
can think whatever they want but I you
know I respectfully disagree I think
about free soloing is that it's
fundamentally a fairly slow and peaceful
activity it doesn't have to be extreme
doesn't have to be crazy I mean you know
if you're free soloing at a low level
it's more analogous to hiking or
scrambling in the mountains and
everybody likes to go for a walk in the
woods difficult free soloing is
obviously not quite the same as going
for a hike in the woods you know it can
still be done well and and done safely
and then a little forest I made a couple
little walls I could have added the
river through the middle but I skipped
that
I'll go back to normal I'm gonna
hopefully be in Yosemite and they climb
some walls again yeah then we'll just
see I want to see no no big climbing
plans yet I mean I guess I bring you
know light hurts some kind or matches or
flint or something of you know a knife I
know a tarp otherwise I bring my book
and I'm very my headphones every you
know like a mp3 player some kind but I
don't think that would keep me alive
very long what do we think does this
look like you somebody do yeah yeah
really good I wanna see my coolest
nature experience I mean it's a bit of a
random story but I on site sold this
this mountain in Zion once this thousand
foot climb so basically did it by myself
first try without a rope so I'd never
been out there didn't really know it was
going on made to the top of the wall and
it had snowed a lot in Zion so there was
snow everywhere and normally you would
repel back down a thousand feet of the
route I didn't have a rope obviously cuz
I was priests only and so instead I
decided to scramble another 2,000 feet
up to the rim of the actual canyon where
I'd pick up a trail and then hiked down
a normal tourist row and at all was
starting to feel pretty extreme because
yeah I've never been there I didn't know
what I was doing and I couldn't really
tell her I was going was it snowy and
then I found some bighorn tracks
basically followed these bighorn tracks
all the way up to the rim so it's sort
of like off a freaking goat managed to
to water a sheep I guess managed to
meander way up to the rim you know
surely whatever the go went up I can go
up followed it for like 2,000 feet made
it to the rim it all worked out and I
say never actually saw the animal but I
did follow the tracks for a very long
way you know I felt pretty rod to begin
with only one more step for me to feel
like I had some spiritual connection
with the actual sheep you know that it
had saved me or that it you know my
ancestor had come back in the form of go
to guide me to safety whatever whatever
you know it's hard to know but Rosario
was pretty cool yeah I filled it I think
I think it's done ski this is by far the
the weirdest thing I've been asked to do
this is my art
shibam this is the first time I've
created art since I was a child is that
pretty good this was my attempt at
painting Yosemite Valley and if you want
to see a better version interview 70
Valley see it in pre solo
it's 10,000 times better than this
painting maybe actually probably more
than that maybe maybe 10 million times
better than this painting can you
recognize the Sentinel yep Sentinel
ok good good see all three formations is
perfect yeah yeah they're really they're
really five elements to this piece I
think no no no no no this is a technical
brush work